is limited by the capacity that's the
student has so you have two types of
teachers generally you'll have the one
who goes hey you guys I want you to have
all your crap together and then I'll
coach you okay then you have another
type of a teacher who goes this is what
I have to work with this is what they're
lacking before I can do that
so I'm going to give them what they're
lacking that's that's how we do it here
okay so we're playing the long game okay
you quit early came in with crap and
you're left with crap okay you had too
much crap so we can't show you the are
so we have to do things like body
conditioning we have too many weak
people we have to do things like
stretching we have too many stiff people
we have to do things like developed body
wisdom we have too many people who think
that a boo boo is a life-threatening
injury because they haven't been
athletes their whole life right we have
to deal with stress management we have
to deal with nutrition we have to deal
with sleep hygiene all these things
because people don't have the discipline
they didn't come in with the discipline
to train daily
daily training is something people just
can't do it would be one thing to go
well therefore you suck get out but
instead we cultivate discipline we give
people the tools to cultivate discipline
so then they can do daily training so
then they can start to learn the art
the training paradigm of Budo is
Confucian and it's not based on an hour
here or two a week it does not work okay
so we do a lot of things like that the
same thing goes with you Kimi when you
learn Kimi we teach you the front
forward roll we teach you the back break
flaw as you progress as Naga is let more
loose on you on you and you can me
you'll find those don't really cut it
I might have to learn this contracting
centre-back break fall or I might have
to learn that going forward back rate
fall I might have to learn a front break
fall okay at least even before that they
roll with no arms or even before that a
jumping roll right we don't start out
with jumping rolls right even the basic
geometry that we use for the beginner
roll is shoulder to hip but as you
become advanced that's that would get
you killed
okay that doesn't work you need to know
this kind of barrel roll right which you
can't teach to the beginner because the
balance isn't there they can't do it
same thing goes with just technical or
architectural proficiency
get yourself in the ballpark and then we
can keep adding things so at this dojo
we have this long-term mentoring program
that's why we don't do walk-ins you
can't come in and start and sign up and
go you can't do it you're entering into
a mentorship relationship which means
you're being individually coached got it
it's why we don't take every person that
goes through a trial period it's like
you're not coachable for the environment
I have right now there's too many needy
people right now and I don't have time
for the amount of need that you require
to get you in the ballpark okay so you
get in the ballpark you learn EQ order
and you just go step to the outside
control the elbow put the elbow under
you go down and you should know by
default then it's wrong it's got so many
things wrong with it that it would
actually not work well the same way that
forward roll it will not work it'll get
you so you can practice you can develop
skills so you could eventually get to
answer those kind of questions
same thing with daily training daily
training will not will not work if you
don't have disciplined sleep hygiene
nutrition stress management proper
worldview you will not be able to do it
it will kill you daily training will
sabotage you if you don't have those
things and
you will hate you will hate what you're
doing and the world will pull you with
these distractions and it spends inertia
towards pleasure seeking and you will
have no reason to do this and you will
fade out the door so get you in the
ballpark that's how we're doing
everything and my caution to everyday
she is the worst thing you can tell
yourself is I got it I got it okay you
should come ready to class every day
ready to throw away what you were doing
the day before and I give you my my
teachers one of one of the few things
last things he said to me near near his
unexpected death was one lifetimes not
enough okay so if he's got four decades
on you you probably should not be saying
I got it okay come in ready to know
realistically you probably aren't going
to catch me I'm probably not going to be
able to show you everything that I have
learned or everything that I'm still
struggling with everything I'm still
experimenting with in the short time we
have together so then there's no way
that you got eco-hula on day one things
are starting to be you can think of it
as I'm being fine-tuned okay or I'm
being reshaped or I'm being
sophisticated if you need a positive
turn on it go ahead that that's not
inaccurate but we get into problems when
we think that this is another variation
because that would make the two equal
and they're not equal one one is going
to work and one is not going to work and
I'm sure you've all had enough you kill
Ruta reps right where either your hookah
wasn't ready it was in G was uh it was a
beginner who care somebody who is not
unconsciously fulfilling the training
culture through a misunderstanding of
hookahs role and they don't go down and
you can't get that elbow under you see
those those are aha moments I must not
be doing it right I need to get the next
step okay what we usually do instead is
this you can't wouldn't do it or I just
I just need to go faster right these are
this is the wrong mindset allow the art
to be infinite where one lifetime is not
enough allow it to be them allow
yourself to suck
allow yourself to be in in a constant
need and capacity for further refinement
further improvement that's going to make
a much more tolerable Budo